[helmet clanging]
[knight groaning]
[armor clanging on ground]
Toby Capwell: Poor old R-Patz
looks like a pile of garbage, I'm afraid.
Hi, I'm Toby Capwell.
I'm curator of arms and armor
at The Wallace Collection
in Central London,
but I'm also a practitioner.
Since I was a kid, I've been riding horses
and fighting in armor.
I've taken part in competitions,
armored combat all over the world.
And today we're going to
be looking at the treatment
of medieval arms and armor in cinema.
[punching]
[laser gunfire]
[armor clanging]
Oh, stop! Stop.
Did you see that?
He just got shot in the
armor, and it knocked him,
but it didn't stop him.
And in a complete armor,
a medieval knight can suffer
horrendous physical punishment
that would kill an unarmored
person [snaps] like that,
but you can take the hits.
And in armored combat,
there are times when you decide
to let your opponent hit you
because you know you can take it
and you're gonna do something else.
You're not gonna waste time defending
what doesn't need to be defended.
And the armor in this
clip takes on, again,
narrative significance. It's storytelling.
He can take a shot right in the chest,
so that's a pretty big character point,
wouldn't you think?
He's not clunking around, all cumbersome.
He moves like a real knight.
I've been jousting and
fighting in armor for 30 years.
I've built a lot of
different kinds of armor,
working with different
craftsmen all over the world.
Real armor of the late Middle Ages,
the Renaissance, is like a steel skin.
It's not bulky.
It's your shape.
The armor should fit you like a skin.
It should follow your musculature.
It doesn't have to be a
lot of space under there.
It's fitted. It moves with you.
The plates are hardened and
tempered medium-carbon steel,
so they don't have to be thick and chunky.
They need to glide over each other
and move like you move.
Mando: Tell me where the Mandalorians are,
and I'll walk out of
here without killing you.
Toby: He hardly ever takes his helmet off,
and yet you know everything
about his expression,
his feelings, his character.
Historically, a knight has a very close,
personal relationship with his armor.
The armor is responsible for his safety,
but he's also the guy who's
gonna mold your character.
That's never really been
explored until this.
Stormtrooper: I said, where are they?
Toby: It's got a couple of possible
sources of inspiration. On the one hand,
it looks a lot like
an ancient Greek hoplite's helmet,
the ancient Greek heavy infantry of, like,
500 BC or of thereabouts.
These very distinct spectacled helmets
with these eye cutouts,
they have a nasal for the nose
and then the cheeks brought in.
In the Bronze Age, they're trying, again,
to get as much protection for the face
and the head as they possibly can.
So that's where that really closely set
kind of spectacled profile comes from.
That was then imitated in the Renaissance.
In the 15th century in Italy,
and very rapidly everywhere else,
people became fascinated with
the classical world again,
and they started looking
back to the ancient Greek
and Roman precedent.
And this style of helmet
became fashionable again
in Italy and Venice,
in the Venetian empire, specifically.
In the 15th century,
most used by infantry,
shooting crossbows and firearms and...
more lightly armored troops.
And in the ancient Greek period,
they were the heavy infantry,
but they still had shields to hide behind,
and they're actively
protecting their faces
as well as relying on their armor.
I'd give this a 10, absolutely.
[knight grunting]
"Vikings" is a fantasy.
You should really treat it as a fantasy.
There's a lot of things
to like about this show.
And that makes it almost
the more tragic for me,
because those Anglo-Saxons
are all wearing late-16th-century helmets.
The burgonets, with the
high comb and the peak.
They are 800 years wrong.
[armor clanging]
[man screaming in pain]
The leather biker gear.
There is almost no historical evidence
for leather clothing.
Almost across the board,
people in the past did not
make clothes out of leather.
It's a distinctly modern thing.
[horse neighing]
[man shouting]
The ax is fine.
I don't have a problem with the ax.
I do have a problem with
none of the main
characters wearing helmets.
You can't go anywhere
near a battle like this
without a helmet.
So, I mean, someone like Ragnar Lodbrok
or someone of that stature
would have an amazing mail coat.
He'd have jewelry.
He'd have big, thick, gold stuff on him.
He'd have a gilded sword.
He does not have to look
like a pile of leather crap.
I'm gonna give it a three.
[dramatic music]
[armor clanging]
That is metal.
Nothing else looks like metal
but metal in close-up.
All that decoration is etched
into the steel with acid.
This is film armor as good as it gets.
[weapons clanging]
[dramatic music]
Now, there are lots of
great spraying techniques,
and you can spray plastic
to look reflective.
And increasingly it looks
more and more like metal,
but it doesn't behave like metal.
Their armor, you can see,
it's a little bit too flexy.
There's something about metal that,
it has a weight, it has a rigidity
that rubber and plastic
and polyurethane don't have.
[swishing mace]
[men shouting]
He walks into the battle,
and you know everything you
need to know about this guy,
and it's all coming out through his gear.
They've taken real
15th-century armor styles,
mostly German, and then
turned it up to 11.
Sauron is wielding a mace.
And maces are real.
It's a hafted weapon with
a wooden or a steel haft
with a flanged or bladed head on one end.
So all the weight of the
weapon is balanced to the end.
And it's a concussion weapon.
And you're trying, rather than to cut
or pierce your opponent,
you're trying to smash
through their defenses.
That is way bigger in proportion to him
than any real maces were.
Real German Gothic high medieval maces
of the 15th century are,
they're usually pretty short.
They're just a little bit more than a foot
or a bit more long.
The heads are quite small,
but they got these really
sharp blades on them,
and you're focusing your
energy on a really small area.
A weapon doesn't need to be massive
to have the effect that it needs to have.
But massive always reads well on screen,
especially when you've
got a dark lord of Mordor.
And how successfully does
it use armor and weapons
to bring its characters
and its themes across?
I gotta give this 10 as well.
[armor clanging]
Poor old R-Patz
looks like a pile of garbage, I'm afraid.
This is a mishmash.
There are a couple of elements,
the shoulders and the body armor,
that are vaguely 15th century,
but they're about a generation
too late for Agincourt.
His helmet is just ridiculous.
I mean, that has a vaguely
16th-century profile to it,
but it fits badly.
It's too big. It's clunky.
[knight groaning]
[armor clanging on ground]
Ah, come on, man. What is this?
[armor clanging]
Well, this is obviously
supposed to be the battle
of Agincourt in 1415.
[sighs]
[clicks tongue]
[producer laughing]
At the real battle of
Agincourt, it was very muddy.
The French had 10,000 fully armed knights.
That was the entirety of their army.
They had archers, but
they didn't use them.
The Pas-de-Calais mud is like
this thick, gluey clay stuff,
very difficult to move through.
And it would be difficult,
regardless of what you're wearing.
Armor often gets blamed for
the French defeat at Agincourt,
as if the French were wearing heavy armor
that the English were too
clever to wear or something.
The fact is, the English,
including Henry V here,
were wearing full-plate armor of the time.
The English had 1,500 fully armed knights
whose job it was to protect
those famous archers.
[men shouting]
They go about it sort of the right way,
in that this knight is
someone who's been trained
to fight and kill people
since he was a child,
and he's very, very good at it.
The only way you've got any chance of this
if you're an archer
or an English foot soldier or whatever
is to get six or seven
or eight of your friends
and pile in all at the same time.
Don't take turns. He will kill all of you.
You gotta all go together,
and four or five of you
gotta hold him down,
and then one or two of you
have to stab him in the eyes
and in the gaps in the armor.
You don't stab through the armor.
When King Richard III was killed
at the battle of Bosworth,
they immobilized him. They held him down.
Someone took his helmet off.
They probably cut the chin
strap and took the helmet off,
and then they can do as they like.
They cut off the back of his skull.
They stabbed him right through the brain.
They did whatever they wanted.
I'll give it a one, 'cause they've got mud
and archers working together.
But I can't give it any more than a one.
It's a massive lost opportunity.
[crowd cheering]
[horses running]
It's a legal procedure
where they're determining
the ownership of territory
with a trial by combat.
They're attacking each
other on the wrong side.
If you can see,
they're passing right to
right, which is wrong.
They shouldn't be doing that.
Because your reign hand
is in your left hand,
so it can't wield a weapon.
Your reign hand is in your left,
so your left side is more exposed.
So that's where your shield goes,
and your lance is in your right hand.
Nobody's allowed to be
left-handed in the Middle Ages.
In traditional knightly
mounted combat like this,
you always pass on the
left side to left side.
Unhorsing someone is very difficult,
and it only happens
when certain key factors
all come together.
The timing's got to be right.
The impact, the placement of the lance
on the body's got to be right.
Where he is in his stride of
the horse when he gets hit.
There's lots of things
that kind of contribute
to the likelihood of being unhorsed.
But as a general rule,
it's very, very difficult
to separate a good
horseman from his horse.
[horse running]
[horse neighing]
If this was a later period,
in, like, the 15th century
when you have full-plate armor,
you can be run over by a
horse in full-plate armor
and you'll be just fine.
I've seen it happen.
This is kind of a weird
choice in this film,
because El Cid,
Rodrigo Díaz de Vivar, is a real person,
but he lived in the 11th century,
in the late 1000s.
It's largely looking like
the early- to mid-14th century.
[crowd cheering]
[armor rustling]
Uh-oh, the 16th century two-handed swords
are coming out now.
We assume for some reason
that a bigger sword hits
harder than a little sword.
These are not firearms.
This is not a higher-caliber sword.
[laughing]
They didn't have two-handed
swords in El Cid's lifetime.
What you're seeing Charlton wearing here
is what's traditionally
referred to as string mail.
It's a knitted garment, knitted
with big knitting needles.
So you've got big loops in
the weave of the knitting,
and then they iron it flat,
spray it silver, and it looks like mail,
or they think it does.
It doesn't really look
that much like mail,
but it's been the mail substitute
for years and years and years.
And it's fine for the background,
and I'd still pass it for the background,
but you can't have it in the foreground.
Five out of 10.
The diving suit is very much like armor
in the sense that it protects you
from a hostile environment
of a different kind.
It's a complete fantasy,
because he's not got an air supply.
Diving suits are a real historical thing.
There are designs
going back to the 14th and 15th centuries
in the late Middle Ages,
of designs for diving suits.
The skills of the armorer
would be recruited
for doing something like this.
They work purely on a basic
system of water displacement.
The suit is not watertight;
the water can get in.
You pump air into the helmet,
and it displaces the
water below your face.
But the water, as the
pump is going up and down,
the water goes up like this,
and it sometimes covers your face,
and sometimes it goes down,
and you hope they pump hard enough
to keep you from drowning.
It's dicey, but it's possible.
I give it a seven.
It's very, very interesting.
[iron clanging]
Hey, what's he doing?
Stop that!
[fire hissing]
No, you can't do that.
That's not how you take
a sword apart, I'm sorry.
This whole idea of
melting a sword blade down
and then recasting it in a mold,
which is what they're doing,
you can't do that.
If you reduce the iron or the steel
to its liquid state,
you lose all of the
properties that you want.
If you melt and cast iron in a mold,
it's cast iron, and it
becomes really brittle
and you can't temper it and
you can't heat-treat it.
When you have a lump of iron ore
as it comes out of the ground, yes,
they heat the iron ore
to separate the iron
from all of the silicates
and the rest of the stuff
that it's mixed up with.
You never fully melt it.
You don't bring it up to
the full melting point.
You heat it up until the chemical reaction
occurs in the ore,
which separates the iron
from all of the other junk.
And it sort of gloops down
into the bottom of the bloomery.
Weaponsmiths are very, very careful
never to fully melt anything.
You cannot melt armor
down and make new armor.
I don't care if it looks
good on screen, it's dumb.
I like some of the things
that "Game of Thrones" does with armor,
but that's a fail.
That's a zero.
I love the sort of evil-Statue-of-Liberty
sort of aesthetic here.
I think the star of
that scene is the flail.
Real flails are derived
from farm implements.
The articulated staffs that
are used for threshing wheat.
And if you have a feudal peasant army
and they need to take whatever
hurty things are to hand,
a flail, you know, agricultural
implements are good.
It's a staff with just
an eyebolt articulation
and then another piece of wood.
When such an idea is
weaponized more extensively,
they add a short length of chain
between the staff and the head.
Flails almost exclusively
are a lower-class,
a common soldier, infantry weapon.
The knights didn't use them.
Because they're kind of scary
and they have an inherent
mechanical intrigue,
they've become much more famous
and much more popular to the kind of
popular conception of the medieval knight
than they really deserve to be.
But it's great here.
I mean, I get it. Totally works here.
No flail was ever that big.
No flail ever had a chain that long.
But in this context it works great.
I can't think of another weapon
that would have the kind of visual
and story, character-driven impact
that this has in this scene.
It's gotta be a 10 out of 10.
[man screaming]
He'd be dead.
Be very dead.
One man can't attack a
shield wall like that.
[men screaming]
Nobody ever used rectangular shields.
I mean, that's ridiculous. It's stupid.
And real early medieval shields,
which were all circular
as far as we can tell,
if air can get through,
then a lot of other
things can get through.
Most real shields of this period
are made out of boards
placed edge to edge,
sort of like this.
But they're placed properly edge to edge,
and they're glued, and they're sealed.
And there's arguments,
good arguments to be made for them
then being edged with rawhide
or sometimes covered with hide
or textile and glue.
You should not be able to see
that much air through your shield.
[men screaming]
[armor clanging]
[man shouting in pain]
He's been stabbed right through the chest
between those plates.
They're showing you
how their own
made-up, silly armor doesn't work.
Now, maybe if he gets
hit full in the chest
with a spear that's wielded by someone
who knows how to use it,
his padded textile and mail armor,
which is what he should be wearing,
or even maybe a scale armor,
maybe it wouldn't stand up either.
Now, I'm sorry,
I can't find anything to hold on to.
That's a zero.
[horse running]
[man shouting]
[armor clanging]
Bad lance technique.
I'll give them a pass on
that, 'cause they wouldn't
have known what good lance technique is.
It's a very common thing
in jousting sequences in movies
that they lower their lance
to a horizontal,
and then they kick on and gallop along.
And they're galloping along
with their lance on the level.
You don't do that.
You're sitting on a horse,
you've got 12 feet of pine lance,
and the horse is going
up and down like this,
and you've got it here.
It's inevitable that it's
gonna start to do this.
And it's got a steel head on the end.
There's weight right
out on the end of that.
And pretty soon this thing
is going up and down,
and you couldn't hit a
barn door with the thing.
You've got no chance of controlling
where that spear goes.
And you get the horse going,
and then you won't have to
worry about your opponent
until the last second or
so of the interaction.
And then it comes down. Boom.
It takes practice.
If you're too late, you miss.
If you're too early,
you get tangled up and look like an idiot.
But if you get it right,
you're always on.
A lance came down,
it got tangled up with
my lance in a joust,
and it came down, and the steel spearhead,
which has three prongs like this,
two of the prongs went past my hand
and the third one bypassed the defenses
of my armor, the gauntlet.
It went just under the plate,
through the leather glove and into me.
I finished the competition
before I even realized I
needed to go get sewn up.
[armor clanging]
Lancelot: Yield, sir!
I have the advantage.
Toby: Now, again, this is all metal armor.
It's all aluminum,
aluminum sprayed black
or aluminum polished,
but look how good it looks.
They worked hard to do
what they were doing,
and they knew what they were doing,
and I think it deserves a seven.
[armor clanging]
Traditional ranged weapons,
like the longbow and the crossbow,
the projectile isn't moving that fast,
but it's still moving way fast enough.
You can't block arrows.
Knight: Remove the hood and the mask.
[dramatic music]
[Toby laughing]
Toby: It's an interesting
outfit he's got on.
You know, who has he come as?
He's got a vaguely 11th,
early-12th-century helmet,
but he's got full-plate armor under there
like the 16th century or something.
I'd give it a two
because it's funny and it's Nicolas Cage.
[producer laughing]
Oh, it's funny.
I guess that's worth something.